[Music]
you've probably seen both Hercules and
The Little Mermaid but have you ever
thought about how the characters connect
stay tuned to find out the thread that
links the two together are you new
around here don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things for more great videos like
this now let's get into this Disney
Princess Theory Ariel and Hercules are
cousins we all watch Disney movies
growing up and if you didn't pause this
video right now and go have a disney
marathon for the rest of us we probably
took each Disney movie as its own little
world you might even say we've made it a
part of our world and for two hours the
film's creators crafted a little
universe for us to explore they set the
rules in the boundaries in some Disney
movie worlds people had magic powers in
others they didn't the world's rarely if
ever crossed over but when you only
think about Disney characters within the
bounds of their specific movies you may
be missing the bigger picture the
creators of the movies could have been a
whole lot smarter than we gave them
credit for maybe just maybe they
connected some of the characters and
some of the movies but they did it so
discreetly that you would have to pay
ridiculously close attention to catch on
well lucky for you our team has that
kind of time
to pay attention to these films so you
don't have to and while we were
rewatching and re watching again
something hit us that had us positively
shook Ariel and Hercules could be
cousins yep you heard that right Ariel
from The Little Mermaid and Hercules
from the film we know what you might be
thinking the movies are from two
completely different worlds one takes
place under the sea and the other
partially in some weird Greek heavens
but just wait we're gonna break it down
for you in order to do that we need to
take a little stroll down Greek
mythology Lane let's start with Zeus so
Zeus is actually the youngest and oldest
son of gods Cronus and Rhea
[Music]
well what happened was that Cronus
learned one of his children would
overthrow him so he began to swallow all
of his children once they were born he
had already swallowed five of his
children including Hades and Poseidon
and he was planning on swallowing Zeus
as well but then his wife Freya tricked
him she wrapped a stone in swaddling
clothes and gave that to Cronus instead
of Zeus
she then hid Zeus in a cave while he was
there he was raised by nymphs and met
his first wife named meatus who stands
for wisdom she told him to disguise
himself as an Olympian cupbearer and
trick his father into drinking poisoned
his wine Zeus his father got so sick
from the wine that he threw up all of
Zeus's sibling yeah probably should get
that checked out sounds like a digestive
issue anyway their new births meant that
even though Zeus was technically their
little brother he was now older than
them so let's pause for a moment so how
long exactly does it take for Greek gods
to digest their children unpause so the
new births of Zeus is siblings meant
that even though Zeus was technically
their little brother he was now older
than them yet it so because he was the
oldest everyone followed him he and his
brothers all do lots to figure out how
they would divide up the world
Zeus got the sky Hades got the
underworld and Poseidon got the sea so
you probably know how all of this fits
in with Hercules Hercules was the son of
Zeus but unlike the Disney version the
actual Greek version of his birth is a
little Messier Zeus was married to Hira
but he wasn't always faithful he
eventually took interest in a mortal
woman and she became pregnant she then
gave birth to Hercules who was half
mortal the Disney story is a bit cleaner
but can you blame them no one really
wants to watch a movie where the dad is
a cheater anyway the most important part
here is that Zeus is the father of
Hercules remember Zeus is brother
Poseidon he got rule of the sea while
ruling the sea Poseidon fathered of many
children one of those would be Triton
does that name ring a bell you know I
haven't been this choked up since I got
a hunk of moussaka caught in my throat
it should but don't worry if it doesn't
yet
we'll make everything clear in a second
so Triton was the mermen son of Poseidon
it was said that when he blew in his
conch shell horn he could calm the sea
or frighten off enemies theoretically he
is known as the father of all mermaids
but more specifically he's Ariel's dad
from The Little Mermaid so let's get
down to the family line here Ariel is
Triton's daughter
Triton is the son of Poseidon who is the
brother of Zeus and Zeus is Hercules his
father so that would make Ariel and
Hercules cousins once removed okay stay
with us yes maybe the two movies were
released 12 years apart The Little
Mermaid was released in 1989 and
Hercules released in 1997 but isn't it
still possible the creators may have had
these cousins in mind when they wrote
Hercules if you're wondering why there
didn't seem to be any connection between
Zeus and Poseidon in Hercules it's
because the brothers weren't exactly
best friends when Zeus Hades and
Poseidon drew lots to determine who
would get to rule what it was basically
their way of getting away from each
other
Zeus remained in the sky not even coming
down to visit his half mortal son
Hercules Hades remained in the
underworld and Poseidon remained in the
sea can we really blame decidin though
think about it if your brother were some
big superstar God who ruled the sky what
do you really want to visit that often
you'd probably rather stay in the sea or
under the sea where you were the big
fish on campus he does however make a
few appearances in the film and other
remakes for instance in the film you can
see Poseidon at the party that
celebrates the birth of Hercules later
he's also one of the gods that is
imprisoned by Hades and the Titans and
then eventually freed by Hercules tingle
in Hercules the animated series Poseidon
shows up pretty often and is lovingly
referred to as Popo if we want to get
even deeper into this theory let's take
a look at a specific episode of Hercules
the
series called Hercules and the son of
Poseidon in it Poseidon even introduced
his Hercules to his son Triton the two
both go to the same school called
Prometheus Academy the two boys
initially don't have much in common but
they bond after a sea monster is
released forcing them to team up to
fight it now this was obviously before
Triton grew up and had Ariel but
regardless it shows the connection
between Triton and Hercules and that the
two may have even known each other in
Disney's show once upon a time Poseidon
and his wife give birth to Ursula in
this story Poseidon uses Ursula to lure
sailors and harm them upset by this
request
Ursula steals a magic bracelet and gains
human legs and runs away after many
years past the sighting has Ariel help
him travel to meet with his daughter
Ursula who is by that time an adult so
even though the storyline differs a bit
from movie to television show the fact
still remains that the characters are
all intertwine honestly it's crazy that
we never noticed this before all it
would have taken is one Greek mythology
course and we would have picked up on
this immediately if teachers want to
make Greek mythology more interesting
they should definitely teach it with
Disney characters as the examples we
might be more likely to pay attention
though we've just gone through a
ridiculous number of reasons that prove
that Ariel and Hercules are most likely
cousins there are lots of people on the
internet who don't really believe this
theory after looking at all of the
evidence it seems crazy that someone
wouldn't believe all these facts but
there are some hardcore conspiracy
theorists on the Internet
so of course they're gonna come up with
some counter theories we'll take you
through a few of them and then you can
decide what to believe for yourself one
theory says that just because Poseidon
has a son named Triton that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's the same King
Triton from The Little Mermaid but come
on how many superhuman mermaid write-ins
could there be swimming around in the
ocean our guess is not that many but the
theory goes on to say that if King
Triton were actually Poseidon's son then
Ariel would have some knowledge of her
godly nature in the film it doesn't seem
like she knows anything about her
heritage the problem that we have with
this theory
is that ariel is pretty young when the
Little Mermaid takes place and then she
runs off to go live on land with humans
so maybe her father had been meaning to
tell her about her powers and how she
came from gods but he was waiting for
her to get a little older maybe he
wanted her to live a relatively normal
childhood before she had to worry about
living up to actual gods so we can't
just assume that because Ariel didn't
seem to know about her lineage she
wasn't a part of the godly family also
if we're remembering correctly
Hercules also spent most of his life not
knowing where he came from
so if anything Ariel not knowing about
her lineage just makes her more like
Hercules than not this theory by Amino
user babby still has one more point
though if you look at the Triton
pictured in the Hercules television
series he looks quite different than the
king that were used to granted the
television series took place when
Hercules was a bit younger but that
doesn't explain why Triton is green and
looks more like a fish in a series than
he does in a Little Mermaid babby used
this photo to prove that King Triton and
Triton Poseidon son are in fact not the
same person because Hercules and the
Little Mermaid do not take place in the
same universe will admit that the
version of Triton from the television
series does look quite different from
the one in the Little Mermaid but when
you think about it characters don't
always look exactly the same when
there's a television remake of a movie
and secondly we don't really know the
puberty process that mermaids and mermen
go through what if they all start out
green and fish like and then as they get
older they lose their green coloring
gained a ton of muscles and start
looking more like the characters in The
Little Mermaid another theory by
bloggers for references sake points out
that the theory that Ariel and Hercules
are related relies completely on Greek
mythology as we've mentioned previously
the Disney movies do not strictly follow
Greek mythology if they were going off
real Greek mythology then even the title
Hercules is wrong Hercules is actually
the Roman version of the character
the Greek version was here eclis another
discrepancy is that in the Greek version
Hercules is the son of a mortal woman
and Zeus while in the movie Hercules is
the son of the goddess Hera and Zeus
there are also supposed to be nine muses
and Hercules but the movie only
showcases five because of all these
discrepancies we can't really assume
that any part of either movie is an
exact mirror of Greek mythology also if
we take a look at Ariel's family we will
notice a few more places where the story
doesn't follow mythology in the Little
Mermaid cartoon it's mentioned that
Ariel's grandfather is named Neptune not
Poseidon and that Neptune was a normal
Merman and not a god in the Little
Mermaid 3 it's also revealed that
Ariel's mother was Queen Athena it's not
the same Athena from Hercules which may
just mean that an Ariel's family they
like to give their children names that
reflect Greek gods and goddesses this
second counter theory we just talked
about has more valid points in the first
we do just automatically assume that
because Ariel's father is named Triton
that he is the same Triton from Greek
mythology and that the whole story falls
in line with the old Greek tales but if
we take the names away there are a lot
of things that don't match up there are
great arguments for both sides
ultimately it's up to you to decide do
you think that Ariel and Hercules are
cousins if so do you think that they
know it let us know your thoughts in the
comments that's it for Disney Princess
Theory Ariel and Hercules are cousin do
you believe this theory let us know in
the comments thanks for watching
[Music]